got a new number for you brady it's
another biggie 10 so the
272 thousands
again we have done bigger but this is
bigger than a google it's quite a lot
bigger than google
so this number really is the latest
estimate
on the number of universes that you can
get out of string theory does that mean
if string theory's right
there are that many universes existing
like multiverses or that's the number of
different it's kind of yeah you think of
it as the size of the multiverse so do
they all exist that's hard to say um
but they could all exist and they may
all exist but yeah whether i wouldn't
want to say confidently that they're all
existing now there's the potential
potentially that they they could all be
found at some point in the history of
the multiverse
why are there so many possible universes
that you can get from string theory you
might have heard the number 10 to the
500 used in this context that was the
old estimate that goes back about 20
years this goes back about five six
years this this is this sort of updated
estimate but okay where does it come
from so string theory is a sort of
as as we know is our best candidate for
a quantum theory of gravity but the
funny thing about it is a
ten-dimensional theory so what does that
mean it only really makes sense in 10
dimensions of space and time and that
goes against what you normally think
about because you know we experience
three dimensions of space and one
dimension of time so this there's six
left over in string three for it to make
sense so what we normally say is those
the extra six dimensions are wrapped up
very very small so small we can't see
them okay so there's a very what we call
like a compact shape a compact manifold
that wraps up these six extra dimensions
now the original hope is that you know
you'd wrap it up in one particular way
and then you'd get the the you know a
single unique universe would pop out
it turns out
that there are lots and lots and lots of
different ways you can wrap up
these six extra dimensions so the way
you can think of them think of a taurus
maybe and you can see that has cycles
one going round that ring another one
going around this way
general sort of shapes that you use to
sort of bring this string theory down
from 10 to four dimensions they have so
much structure so much complexity that
when you count up all the possibilities
you get you start arriving at some very
big numbers not just that it's not just
the shapes that are important it's what
you can do with those shapes one of the
things you do is you you have in string
theory you have a you know analogues of
magnetic fields and you can sort of
thread magnetic flux through these extra
dimensions in in loads of different ways
and again that adds to the different
universes you have because for any given
shape that you pick you get a very
particular structure of the sort of
leftover four-dimensional world and if i
choose one shape i'll get one
four-dimensional world with certain
particles certain forces certain just
structure there if i choose a different
one i'll get something different so they
all give something subtly different i
mean i'm not going to pretend i
understand what you're talking about
right but as i understand that you know
there are all these different ways to
pack the hidden dimensions
one of those packing
configurations
results in the universe that you and i
are living in right absolutely do we
know what that one looks like no
right we've never been able to quote the
one that gives what we see so it's a
very good point actually it's a it's
actually a really great point so
there are huge numbers of possible
universes that you can get out of
anything you just do this counting game
you know there are constraints on on how
you can put these magnetic fluxes
through these these weird and wonderful
shapes and and when you do this you get
you get this this counting and actually
this estimate comes from using something
called f theory which don't need to
let's not worry about what it is but it
gives you a way of calculating um the
you know vacuum
universes in a certain type of string
theory called type 2b
that's a technical detail your question
was do any of them look like our
universe actually all of the ones that
come from this counting and this is a
bit of a secret they all have what's
called negative vacuum energy now that's
a bit of a disaster because vacuum
energy is the energy that you have left
over when you sort of take everything
out so you take out all the planets all
the stars all that you have vacuum
energy the energy of the vacuum empty
space so you could ask is it positive is
it negative you might or is it zero you
might think it's zero but generally it's
not zero in all of these cases it's
negative
the thing is on our universe we expect
it's probably positive
okay and the reason is is because um we
see the universe accelerating and that
positive vacuum energy will cause an
acceleration this doesn't lead you to
think maybe string theory is wrong
um
no
not yet it's it's a curious one because
okay okay so one of the things i mean
something else could be causing the
universe to accelerate it could be that
we're in a in one of these vacuum that
we're in one of these universes and the
the the vacuum engine is very small but
negative and what we're experiencing at
the moment is is just some excited state
above that and actually we're still at
positive energy and we're going to roll
eventually the dark energy itself will
settle down to nothing and then we'll
end up in this vacuum that might be a
way out that you could imagine quite
easily well not easily no one knows how
to do it but but you could imagine it so
yes there's this huge number of vacuum
and a huge number i'm saying evacuate
because what i'm really talking about
what you're counting here are actually
the vacuums of the theory okay and the
universe that you would get is the sort
of excitations about it you know you
sort of start putting planets and stuff
in there but but this is what look out
the different sort of baseline points
you can have for each of these sort of
like those sort of like the different
foundations exactly exactly i started
thinking about what some of them might
look like actually this is where i
started going off on one and having a
bit of fun
different shapes will give you different
properties of the underlying universe
when you've got so many as this some of
these universes can be really really big
so they're all got negative vacuum
energy now when you've got a universe
with negative vacuum energy it's
guaranteed to end after a certain time
vast majority of these universes will
end almost instantaneously they'll
barely exist for any time at all those
which have a very small and negative
vacuum energy will live for much longer
more stable they're more stable yeah
exactly
now
there's some of them are going to live
for a really long time like much longer
than the our current age of the universe
like this huge number allows that as we
can imagine the summer really really
long lived
and i started thinking about what would
you know sort of
what would it be like in those places
when you've been around for a really
really long time how would technology
develop for example has technology
developed to sort of gargantuan levels
so you start thinking about moore's law
you know the computing power will double
every two years of course a really
long-lived universe doesn't guarantee
really long-lived inhabitants
absolutely and this is what i'm coming
to right so i said okay so what's
imagine moore's law applied computer
power's doubling every two years or
something unless you try to do it for
for the kind of length of time some of
these really long-lived universes are
going to give you
then you quickly get to
you you exceed the allowed bounds
there's a nice paper by seth lloyd where
he says that the maximum computing power
you can have for a kilogram sized
computer is about 10 to the 50
operations per second you're gonna go
sailing past that point in fact you're
gonna find that you're gonna you're
gonna have to start making bigger
computers so you can fit more energy
into it and then you're going to get
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
until eventually you have to stop
building computers that are reaching all
the way to the cosmological horizon and
you still have got nowhere near where
moore's law would theoretically take you
right so there's no way you're going to
get you can just keep developing
technology in these places you're going
to have to hit some
limit
very quickly on the wider time scales
that we're talking about and then
something's got to give right either it
just stays stable i think much more
likely is that it crashes down and as
society ends you know they've become so
technological they've learned also how
to destroy themselves as we have and
then it starts off again and then it
goes down again then it starts off again
and then it goes down again
that's one possibility
the other is that there is a way to sort
of get around some of these bounds the
big thing the big obstacle is that you
need to start adding energy to the
system to get more computing power from
them and you want that not to turn into
a black hole
so the way to stop things turning into a
black hole is to weaken gravity now it's
possible because of the [ __ ] that some
of these funny shapes
again have leading to much weaker
gravity theories
gravity is much weaker in these universe
so it might be that in some cases
gravity's weaker which means these
bounds limiting technology
are much much weaker about you get much
more technologically advanced and much
faster computing power from these things
and that would be really cool so you can
in some cases you might get really
really beyond what you can even
comprehend advanced civilizations in
fact if you've got weaker gravity as
there would be in some of these
universes you can find generally
everything's much more um
complex for example stars live for much
longer if stars live for much longer
that that also suggests you've got more
time for things to evolve things are
going to get
bigger we're going to get better and
clever and clever and clever and clever
it's going to be much more advanced so
when you start thinking about these
multiverses and all the things that can
happen in them
i mean i think you're just talking about
things that are completely unimaginable
to what we could even comprehend like
the levels of technology that
are just
off the scale beyond even the bounds
that we think exist in our universe that
they're not even restricted by those and
i think that's an amazing place to be
if string theory is correct and there's
some number at the moment it's that
number there but there's some number of
possible
universes
would only one of them actually come
into existence would all of them have a
chance would all of would any exist
simultaneously what does that number
actually mean like how many of those
that's a very good question it's not a
question we can answer without much
better knowledge of string theory what
you're really asking is how are these
these universes distributed in all the
range of possibilities and it might be
that some of them are much more likely
than others we have no idea what that
weighting really is we just don't know
we don't know string theory well enough
to answer that question so it might be
that someone much more preferred in
which case you would say that we're much
likely to be in one of those universes
you ask the question can they all exist
again that's a question you can only
really answer with much better knowledge
of strength what can happen generally in
a system with say two vacuums two two
solutions you can have bubbles of one
appear in the other so you could start
off with the universe where everything's
in one particular state then a bubble
nucleates of the other state and then it
bubbles nuclear and you get this
percolation effect you could have
something like that at a cosmological
level and
these new universes start to appear and
then universes start to appear in
universes and that could happen
to be sure it happens you have to know
about the transition the nucleation rate
of these bubbles and you can't know that
without much much better knowledge of
the shape of what's called the strength
theory landscape which we just don't
know we don't have the tools yet to
calculate
you told me
there are there are these ten dimensions
three that we're quite familiar with
time and then these six little ones
packed and hidden away yeah
uh all of these universes you talk about
here
examples
like that where there are
three out in the open time and six
hidden like is that just limiting us to
that confusion yeah yes yes that could
there be a five dimensional universe
yeah there are five hidden yeah yes
exactly yeah you could you could imagine
that there's certain assumptions that
have gone in here one of the assumptions
is that you've gone down to four
dimensions the other is that you've gone
down to four dimensions on a very
particular type of of shape which are
these collaborators which guarantees a
certain amount of symmetry guarantees
stability it guarantees you can actually
trust your calculations so there might
be many more things that you could
consider we just haven't figured out how
to calculate we haven't figured out to
make sense of them and yeah absolutely
you could imagine scenarios with other
dimensionalities
i sometimes hear that mathematicians and
physicists can think something's right
by gut or instinct they may be proven
right or proven wrong in the fullness of
time does your gut or instinct tell you
that
string theory's on the right track here
with with this
this is this it's a very difficult
question um
i think string theory is a magnificent
theory is this should i take this amount
of universes seriously should i take the
multiverse seriously
it's very early days to do that
i mean the moment this is just a
counting game they count a number of
solutions that you could get
there's so much more to ask
is are these even all consistent do
these even all make sense
or is it a subset of them it makes sense
which ones do make sense you know this
this is ongoing research so one of the
things that i think people sometimes
criticize string three for is they you
know they say oh you're talking about
these multiverse you're talking about
all the you know this all these
possibilities it's not testable it's not
but actually string theories aren't
being that reckless they are looking at
these and really trying to understand do
these actually make sense that did this
was just a counting game but let's try
and actually really build one and and
study what it does and can we actually
get it and and that's what people are
doing and there's this whole swan plan
program trying to understand that and i
think um there's actually much more
rigor than perhaps i think maybe the
wider community realizes going on by
string theory is that they're really
pushing and
and probing this their theory to try to
understand better
what is the meaning of these numbers
what is what are the meaning of all the
universes that appear can i trust them
all
and where is our universe in all of that
for more big numbers and mind-boggling
cosmology why not check out tony's brand
new book it's called fantastic numbers
and where to find them a cosmic quest
from zero to infinity there's a link in
the description
and to really give your brain a workout
you should be visiting our episode
sponsor brilliant i've told you
countless times about their great
courses and lessons
filled with interactivity designed by
real pros
but in a world going crazy with wordles
and sudoku's and the like you really
need to check out brilliant's daily
challenges like these ones here
i love them they're always really
cunning but they've also got like a
sense of humor that's another thing i
like about brilliant it kind of makes
you smile
to check them out go to brilliant.org
number five using that url will give you
20 off a premium subscription
again check out the links in the video
description
it does
my problem with it is that it's
completely untestable as far as i can
tell
in that you know
this idea that that the sun is just one
star for example it's a hypothesis and
then you learn more and more about other
stars out there by observing them by
making observations of them and then
actually you find yeah it's true
actually the sun is no different from
any other star the multiverse as far as
i can tell we can't test physically
because the idea that there are other
universes out there well how do we
communicate with them